nearly two-thirds or 64
millennials ages 25 to 40 years old say
they have they have at least one regret
about purchasing their current home
according to a new poll
of more than 1400 u.s homeowners and
from bank rate
only 45 of gen x 41 to 56 and 33
of boomers 57 and 75 have reported some
type of remorse about the current home
they found but overall having some
dissatisfaction is pretty common about
of all homeowners have at least one
regret about their home among all
homeowners including millennials the
most common regret is underestimating
how much the maintenance expenses and
other hidden costs associated
with buying and owning a home other
types of regress focus on the size of
the home and the finances involved in
the process including the mortgage
payment and rate
adam i'm gonna turn this to you yeah
i've said it before and i'll say it
again home ownership
ain't all that it's cracked up to be and
there's big three things you need
there's the big three things that you
need to keep in mind and they said it in
this article
oh i didn't realize that maintenance was
gonna be this much there's three things
you have to keep in mind if you're gonna
be a homeowner that you do not have to
pay
if you're renting maintenance is one of
them taxes
is the other big one and then insurance
all right homeowners insurance
so people don't get into that they think
oh i'm gonna get this house i can make
the payment it's all good the interest
rate is pretty reasonable
sounds good i'm gonna just buy the house
it seems great and they forget about
these big three factors the big three
expenses that you're gonna have to come
out of pocket for
and you touched on this earlier be wary
of where you're getting your
your advice you touch on this earlier
and when you hear a realtor or someone
who's a developer say
why would you put your why would you
rent you're throwing all your money away
you're throwing all your money away
renting who's giving that advice
like you said someone that wants to sell
a house exactly and and you said well
you know be patient stay in the market
stay in the market why would you leave
the market who's saying that
somebody that ultimately probably works
on wall street so
yeah julie swenson right now just gave
five bucks and she said i don't agree
with the home prices due to birth rates
we are easily going to see appreciation
the next five years right
so julie here's my response to you i
don't disagree
that real estate is a bad investment
today here's why hear me out let me tell
you how i'm processing this
when inflation takes place who wins
whatever that can't be duplicated
let me say one more time when inflation
takes place who wins
whatever that can't be copied and
duplicated what does that mean you
cannot copy more land
you cannot duplicate more land prime
land is going to be valuable
for a very very long if you got premier
premier land
located in a place where families are
going to want to go and birth rates is
going up they're going to want like
let's just say take the best private
schools
okay take the best private school in
omaha nebraska
take the best private schools in
whatever in la in chicago in dallas in
florida in miami take the best private
schools and then go to the best
community in that
close to the private school maybe it's a
gated community maybe it's a good area
that community forever is going to do
well as long as that private school
does well because families with money
who can afford to pay
15 20 30 40 000 for private school are
willing to go live
near that school so i do agree with her
the only challenge i have isn't the fact
that
long-term real estate is not going to go
up the challenge i have is people
who are buying stuff that they cannot
afford people who are living a lifestyle
today that's not really their lifestyle
overextending that is that is not a
smart move to be making
and a lot of people are making a move
right and it might be some of these
millennials that now have the regrets
right about buying the house you know
that that's a shocker
for a young person um there's no
landlord to call when the plumbing goes
down or the roof leaks or something like
that and that's expensive
have you had to have a plumber come over
that's hundreds and hundreds of dollars
it's unbelievable the other thing that
this story about the millennials you
know points to me
is have a little gratitude i mean
they're always looking for the negative
thing about regrets and this and that
how about you know no one put a gun to
your head to make you buy these houses
and i think it also speaks to the fact
like a little bit what you mentioned
adam they weren't looking for advice
from people that maybe were
owners of homes and what they should
look out for maybe a little arrogance
creeps into it like they have all the
answers and i'm just gonna buy a home
now
because i can afford a down payment but
there are some some hidden
little misery items there that you got
to prepare yourself for and one other
thing is
um you know they talk about the american
dream you talked about financial freedom
a little bit ago you used that
terminology the the american dream
back in the day where it's ironic that
baby boomers a third of them
have regrets whereas two-thirds of
millennials have regrets
and ultimately i think that's because
the american dream has changed american
dream back in the day
when you know our parents were really
coming to age in the 80s when we were
all
basically being born um was to
have a house in the suburbs let's say
work in the same job for the next 40
years get your gold wash get your
pension
retire kind of have stability the
american dream has changed
significantly these days that it's all
about work from anywhere financial
freedom
uh travel live your best life and not
necessarily being tied down
i think that i'm a huge proponent of is
having high flexibility
and low overhead so look at my life in
the last 12 months i lived in miami
i lived in dallas i lived in boca and we
might be moving again in the next
we are going to be okay so the point is
if i was locked in well pat i'd love to
be a part of valuetainment but i've got
a house in pembroke
true but i want you to think about it
you want to be married one day no
correct you want to have kids one day
yes do you think the uber lifestyle is
going to work if you're married
no do you think no i'm actually not
being funny i'm actually being very
serious but i will tell you one
where it does work so yes i agree at
some point if you have kids you're going
to need a house you're going to be your
car obviously that you you work
that i'm looking at you the guy was you
were vascular coming back after
basketball basketball
you're going to want to teach your kids
how to play basketball you're one of the
best athletes that came out of high
school here playing football you had all
these records with basketball you're an
athletic guy so yeah
so if you want to drop these guys so so
what i'm saying to you is i think
the approach you took to save your money
it is genius on what you did and i think
more people ought to take a play out of
your playbook
but that is with the intentions of
saving money because once you are
married yes
you get to choose what zip code you want
to raise your kids in you get to choose
what private school you want to put your
kids in
if you want to raise your kids with the
religious beliefs that your family has
maybe you want to
raise them with a private school that a
a link to a jewish community if you want
to do that great if you want to put them
in pine crest if you want to put you
could do that you have those options
but it's it's with the plans of
eventually having
choices forever it's not sustainable to
be like that single maybe in new york
yeah
i don't think it's going to be
sustainable i totally agree with you i
totally agree with you i sacrificed in
my all throughout my 30s
to save money not to have major expenses
sacrifice listen you all you it's not
like you
listen you've had more fun than a
hundred single men combined it's not
like you haven't had the phone let's not
say sacrifice like
it was a sacrificial lamb outside of the
bar you're like got a little freaking
you know oh my gosh drinks when i say
sacrifice
meaning i still haven't bought a rolex
for 20 g's
i still haven't bought a lambo for 200
grand could i have yes but i'd rather
save that money invest that money
so when i'm in my 40s i'm not freaking
out stressing over
you also don't even care you have a
certain fashion that you follow
black white blue jeans and shoes and
it's very basic that's kind of hard
i think i think this is something that i
already cut your own hair or somebody
else
i got my i go to this guy rapper tony
but i think
there there is a by the way he looked
great in dallas that hair is ridiculous
i don't know how old rapperton is in his
fifties he's the guy that's
ridiculous he's making he's doing very
well something that i will say
is that you get so caught up
in materialism and consumerism on the
latest gucci belt and then
and and then driving this car and the
fashion there's something just so
awesome and just being comfortable dude
i got a black t-shirt on i got no
jewelry good for you but i feel great
i'm not even saying for me
yeah for our audience sure it's not
about the stuff that materialism
some people about being comfortable i
don't i i think for me it's whatever
drives you
okay i think it's when you broke it down
in your four different whatever drives
you and that drives you i love it
whatever drives him
i love it whatever drives sean i love it
whatever drives me i love it it's
whatever drives the individual
but i think there's more leaning towards
having some of the money in the bank
today because
just assume bad times are usually coming
every five to ten years it's just
every ten years we have a recession that
flat out it's just the numbers run that
way about every ten years five to ten
years yeah
sometimes two to four years but it's
five to ten years we have a recession
and those who are prepared for it guess
what
they end up being called the geniuses
and you can act as much as you want that
you're making real money today
it's not as by the way let me let me
make a prediction to you let me make a
prediction to you
let's just say let's just say let's just
say
let's just say in the next 24 months
dow goes to 25 bitcoin goes to 8 800.
unemployment goes to 8.8 it's kind of
throwing numbers out there okay
unemployment goes to 8.8
taxes go to the roof biden actually does
what he does
okay taxes go to the roof uh money
supply is not looking pretty
china is blowing up growing you know
doing incredible things
okay all of these things that are taking
place
those people that were sitting on
millions of dollars you think they're
shopping the way they are
no no the 300 that they're saying
they're about to cut in how many
different states what was the number
with 300
how many states are being cut nearly 2
million americans will lose that 300
unemployment benefit this summer that's
a lot of people
two million people so that's about to go
away yeah but there's eight million jobs
that are open it just goes to show they
don't want to work
you're right you're right what did
applebee's just announced kai what was
it applebee's that announced they're
hiring ten thousand
people and they're having a hard time
finding it by the way applebee's is
paying bonuses just to a place
what's going on they're begging people
to get a job and they're not wanting
two different directions here where were
you going with all the stats where i'm
going with this when that happens
if that happens okay who then is the
genius two years from now
the people sitting on the cash now with
their money such as who the people that
listen to me and save that money such as
who else
give me big names such as who as far as
warren buffett yeah people are going to
say this flipping conservative money you
know what value
investors this guy yeah by the way it's
not if when this happens what you just
i'm just saying that's actually the
scenario that you just played out i
think is very reasonable in the next
fight so and then people gonna say wow
you know warren buffett you know he
maybe he really maybe monger maybe this
maybe that
so look i'm i'm of the place that we
the moment you no longer listen to the
youngins you have a blind spot
the moment you also don't take counsel
from the old experience just kind of you
also have blind spots by the way i think
it's both though
i think too often we're coming from a
place of well
you know i know what i'm talking about
and all this stuff do you realize
you know i have shoes older than you
those type of lines people say
listen that's showing you got a blind
spot
yeah i got shoes older than you no it's
when i wanted to find out about social
media works i sat next to a girl who was
candy's daughter her name is phoebe she
was 14 years old
she's now uh doing great in her life
shout out to the kennedy family
kenny nelly i'm sitting next to ellen
hawaii uh not ellie
phoebe next message phoebe tell me about
what social media app you're using right
now
and she said seriously yes yeah i said
what grade are you in i'm in 10th grade
ninth grade what social media app you're
using right now
she says everyone's using snapchat i
said snapchat yeah i said not facebook
this is like 10 years ago
she says no everyone's using stats say
can you show me snapchat how does this
work
she shows me snapchat then i'm in
bakersfield the girl named shauna blato
and marlene cormenadas they say pat why
are you not on snapchat so what do you
mean snapchat this is eight nine years
ago
they show me snapchat i listen to them
and i'm like oh this guy's got these
millions of subscribers whatever i'm
listening to the youngins on what's
going on
but if these guys get too cocky with
that they lose if the youngins
don't take the council and say dude
listen i've seen 10 markets
right i've seen 10 ups and downs i'm
telling you may be up to something with
crypto
but i'm just telling you you may want to
take a little bit of experience on what
i've seen happen
over the last i think what you're saying
is that it works both ways yes
everything is cyclical they both have
blind spots when the olden experience
get too cocky
they get destroyed and replaced when the
young and energetic
get too cocky they lose tens of years of
their lives because they could have
saved that ten years
by listening to somebody who made that
mistake four years before they were even
born so i think there's an element of
learning from both
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye